- [Instructor] The distribution
of resting pulse rates
of all students at Santa Maria High School
was approximately normal with
mean of 80 beats per minute
and standard deviation
of nine beats per minute.
The school nurse plans
to provide additional
screening to students
whose resting pulse rates
are in the top 30% of the
students who were tested.
What is the minimum resting
pulse rate at that school
for students who will
receive additional screening?
Round to the nearest whole number.
If you feel like you
know how to tackle this,
I encourage you to pause this
video and try to work it out.
All right, now let's
work this out together.
They're telling us that the distribution
of resting pulse rates
are approximately normal.
So we could use a normal distribution.
And they tell us several things
about this normal distribution.
They tell us that the mean
is 80 beats per minute.
So that is the mean right over there.
And they tell us that
the standard deviation
is nine beats per minute.
So on this normal distribution,
we have one standard
deviation above the mean,
two standard deviations above the mean,
so this distance right over here is nine.
So this would be 89.
This one right over here would be 98.
And you could also go standard
deviations below the mean,
this right over here would
be 71, this would be 62,
but what we're concerned
about is the top 30%
because that is who is going to be tested.
So there's gonna be some
value here, some threshold.
Let's say it is right over here,
that if you are at that score,
you have reached the minimum threshold
to get an additional screening.
You are in the top 30%.
So that means that this
area right over here
is going to be 30% or 0.3.
So what we can do, we can use a z-table
to say for what z-score is 70%
of the distribution less than that.
And then we can take that z-score
and use the mean and
the standard deviation
to come up with an actual value.
In previous examples, we
started with the z-score
and were looking for the percentage.
This time we're looking
for the percentage.
We want it to be at least 70%
and then come up with the
corresponding z-score.
So let's see, immediately
when we look at this,
and we are to the right of the mean,
and so we're gonna have
a positive z-score.
So we're starting at 50% here.
We definitely want to
get to the 67%, 68, 69,
we're getting close and on our table
this is the lowest z-score
that gets us across that 70% threshold.
It's at 0.7019.
So it definitely crosses the threshold.
And so that is a z-score of 0.53.
0.52 is too little.
So we need a z-score of 0.53.
Let's write that down.
0.53, right over there,
and we just now have to figure out
what value gives us a z-score of 0.53.
Well, this just means 0.53
standard deviations above the mean.
So to get the value,
we would take our mean and we would add
0.53 standard deviation.
So 0.53 times nine.
And this will get us 0.53
times nine is equal to 4.77
plus 80 is equal to 84.77.
84.77 and they want us
to round to the nearest whole number.
So we will just round
to 85 beats per minute.
So that's the threshold.
If you have that resting heartbeat,
then the school nurse is going
to give you some additional screening.
You are in the top 30% of
students who are tested.